from the creators of lost which
depending on how you look at it maybe a
good or bad thing comes epic's
mystery-filled adventure from with so
many unanswered questions from is the tv
equivalent of blue balls but i'm here to
provide some relief i cringed saying
that by taking a deep dive into some of
the show's biggest mysteries but before
we begin why not like and subscribe so i
can fly down to la and slap some answers
out of these writers what'd i tell you
frank
it got late and i didn't
i've also left timestamps below so you
can check out all the topics i'll be
discussing where are they season one
doesn't even begin to unravel what is
arguably its biggest mystery however
there are some clues that can help us
narrow it down wherever they are does
not seem to be of this world electricity
conjures itself out of nowhere ethan's
impalement heals in a matter of days and
residents when they try to escape end up
looping back into town every time
wherever this place is the regular rules
of physics and biology don't seem to
apply in episode 9 we see a collection
of victor's drawings drawings which
ethan says tell a story one of these is
of a town in a snow globe is our town
separated from the rest of the world in
which the normal rules of physics and
what we believe are possible can be bent
this would explain many of the show's
supernatural elements like monsters who
only hunt at night and seemingly can't
be killed victor's ability to predict
the future trees that transport people
to narnia and let's not forget the boy
and white's ability to use telekinesis i
don't think this place is some sort of
purgatory i mean if that's the case what
did ethan do to deserve being here my
guess is triple homicide i also don't
think it's a dream boyd's wife abby shot
up the town believing if they die
they'll wake up from the stream but in
episode 9 a voice tells sarah that abby
was wrong in the sheriff's office we see
this map of pinned locations where each
of the townspeople were before their
cars wound up in from town this place
has seemingly transported these people
for a purpose a purpose which is yet
unknown with the introduction of the
lighthouse in episode 10 it's also
possible we're on an island or perhaps
somewhere near ashore the cave drawings
uncovered underneath jim's house show
this lighthouse with what appears to be
people in boats maybe that's how people
got here before cars wherever this
bubble or parallel universe is it's been
happening for a very long time at least
1506 if the numbers in tabitha's dream
are to be believed that's just 10 years
after columbus discovered america and
yes i know it was actually the vikings
who discovered america several centuries
earlier because someone will undoubtedly
correct me in the comments in episode 7
a drunk guy jokingly exclaims that they
might be in a pocket universe and
honestly he might be right this is a
pocket universe oh my god so we don't
really know what these numbers are but
it's totally possible that the latest
number 1978 is the year victor woke up
to find his town brutally murdered
leading me to believe these are the
start dates of some sort of cycle that
repeats over and over again in episode 4
victor says he's been here the longest
and he also carries a very 1970s disco
lunch box could those who fail to escape
one of these cycles become the monsters
for those in the next cycle that would
explain their period clothing and why
you never see a monster wearing any
clothing made after 1978. whoever these
monsters are it seems that it wasn't
their choice to be this way at least
according to the monster jasmine who
talks to kevin so who are they like many
of the big unanswered questions of the
show we don't really know however we
have several clues to help us out we
know that the monsters are bound by a
set of rules they only appear at night
and can't enter a home hanging one of
these talisman without permission we
don't know why these talismans work nor
who planted them in that stone hut where
boyd found them but these objects seem
to be leftovers from previous cycles if
this cycle theory is to be believed the
monsters shouldn't be confused with the
boy in white unlike the monsters he can
be seen during the day and helps our
characters this all points to there
being two large forces of good and evil
using our townspeople like pawns in a
game of chess slight loss spoilers but
the nature of good and evil was a huge
theme explored in that show with the
supernatural characters of jacob and the
man in black using the people on the
island to further their own agendas with
several writers and directors who worked
on lost working on from it's totally
possible that this may be the core of
what's going on and that the monsters
are players on one side of this battle
fun fact the symbol on the talisman
looks like two figures stuck together
and the radio antenna itself looks like
one half of it which leads me to the
voice on the radio throughout the last
half of the season jade and jim create a
radio tower with the hopes of
communicating with well anyone this is
culminated in a wild idea to utilize the
town's magic electricity to power the
antenna to create a signal strong enough
to get out an sos of course as soon as
they get it working a wild rainstorm
comes in matching up with nathan's
theory that if you push too hard to
leave something will push back jim's
able to get a message out but a man's
voice on the other end tells jim that
his wife shouldn't be digging that hole
in the basement the leading theory out
there is that this voice belongs to the
bartender tom who coincidentally enough
knows about the hole in the ground and a
few scenes earlier had a one-on-one
scene with jim's wife where he saw her
taking out a pickaxe to dig he also
thinks the antenna is a dumb idea if it
isn't tom let's just say the evidence
for it being someone else is pretty thin
like if it's one of the monsters one of
the voices or someone from an alternate
universe we simply don't have enough
information speaking of tabitha and her
whole that sounded weird we have these
cryptic cave paintings she uncovers
after falling through the basement
there's a lot going on here so let's
break it down first we have the
reappearance of victor who has been mia
after the massacre at colony house he
seems to be taking instruction from the
boy in white who apparently predicted
that tabitha would fall through this
house victor had dug graves before the
colony house massacre even happened so
someone is feeding him information about
events before they happen he says that
this underground network of tunnels are
where the monsters sleep it's daylight
outside so where are they along the
walls are primitive cave drawings victor
says were made by the monsters and these
drawings seem to be telling a story
let's work our way from left to right
starting with what appears to be the
lighthouse here in red guiding white
stick figures in boats along a river or
inlet around them are what i think are
mountains and trees and in the center a
clearly demarcated line as though they
are passing a threshold just like our
characters came to this town via car
maybe this was how people came before
cars and if that's the case it opens up
different possibilities for how people
can actually get there these symbols
that look like trees or a weird letter f
are the same ones found around the
talisman to the right of the boats we
have a much larger black f and below it
some red symbols which we don't quite
know represent however as we move along
you'll notice this black symbol that has
been a recurring image throughout the
season we still don't know what this
image is but my best guess is that it
represents the town or a place of safety
it can be found in the cellar where
young victor sought refuge as well as
where julie wound up after going through
one of the far away trees it separates a
group of white stick figures from these
two near the top maybe this is meant to
represent sarah and boyd's journey or
two people who tried to make this
journey in the past in the center is
what appears to be a large demonic
figure which our two white stick figures
have crossed over notice here how these
stick figures are now red is this
supposed to represent a new group of
people or are they the monsters
regardless they're gathered around what
appears to be a field of crops with a
white house near the top there's this
group of birds here which has me
thinking about the crows but i'm
wondering why they weren't drawn black
if this is some sequential story told
from left to right it ends with our two
white figures near a broken infinity
loop i've theorized that we might be in
some sort of cycle that repeats itself
over and over as time passes if this
journey is successful maybe it breaks
that infinite loop so it doesn't repeat
again now let's talk about this
lighthouse it's just something so
completely random however if you recall
tabitha's dream from episode 9 i think
we've already been here she travels up a
stone spiral staircase we can also hear
this sort of foghorn noise the same one
boyd and sarah here near the lighthouse
when we see jim hung upside down you can
see a moving light in the window
suggesting it's the light from the
lighthouse traditionally lighthouses
have meant to serve one of two functions
to warn mariners of dangerous shallows
and perilous rocky coasts or to help
guide vessels safely into and out of
harbors we don't know which of these
this lighthouse represents maybe it's
not meant for ships at all but is more
metaphorical and meant for our
townspeople maybe it's a marker that
helps people move from one pocket
universe to another or from one area of
wherever the heck they are to another
and the final cliffhanger of the season
which i hate to say this i thought was
terribly weak was the arrival of a grand
rapids bus into town there's no telling
how many people are on this bus but it's
probably a safe bet that christy's
fiancee is aboard she did say the woman
she loved was in michigan and much of
episode 10 was christy apprehensive
about pursuing a relationship with kenny
because she's still holding on to that
love with her fiance if this show gets
renewed for season 2 i really hope that
they start answering some of these
questions and that this won't turn into
another lost i know i couldn't cover
every mystery in this video but i hope i
was able to shed some light on this
insanely cryptic show thanks for
watching everyone be sure to like and
subscribe and leave a comment below on
your thoughts and theories for more bad
takes you can also follow me on twitter
and instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember there has got to be
an explanation
that none of you [ __ ] people seem to
be looking for it